here on the show we love to shine a
light on people
who are working hard to help other
people and today
we have got this incredible story of
three cancer survivors
and gail's friend and cbs news colleague
david begno went out and filed this
drew gooder report
hi i'm carrie hi i'm shelly hi i'm katie
and we're the cancer cartel i was
diagnosed
with stage four non-hodgkin's lymphoma i
was diagnosed with breast cancer
i battled breast cancer thyroid cancer
and i've had an ongoing battle with skin
cancer
carrie and i have been friends for about
i would say five years now
and me and shelly are sisters katie and
i were talking about how lucky we are to
have made it through our cancer journeys
and
that we were meant for more and the
cancer cartel was born
we accept luxury donated items or
dollars on our website
we sell it and 100 of the proceeds go
directly into the hands of people
fighting cancer
we're going to send you a check in the
mail today oh my gosh
thank you so much oh my god you guys are
awesome
thank you so much i'm just i'm really
grateful or liam
i feel like i'm doing what i'm meant to
do with people i meant to do it with
and that there's nothing that can stop
us on this journey
hey drew it's david begna with cbs news
i am on a very special assignment
here in seattle to surprise carrie katie
and kelly
hello
drew wanted me to surprise you guys with
these this
is amazing are you kidding me
oh my gosh you guys you know what we
never get anything for ourselves i'm
going to start crying i'm not kidding
that's awesome oh oh are you kidding me
thank you oh my gosh we're blown away i
don't
really i don't even know i have no words
coming here to surprise you guys on
behalf of drew incredible
was so exciting for me like this is
personal because my mother had breast
cancer
wow and so i got really emotional
watching
what you all are doing for other people
to pay it forward
we all have stories that we shouldn't be
here and it was
meant to be that we were supposed to be
on this path together i always had the
back of my mind i want to do something
to give back
i just didn't know what that thing was
until these two how does it feel
to be recognized it feels
honestly it feels surreal people have
been so amazing coming on board and
supporters y'all are the true gooders
that make the world
a special place thanks for trying thank
you
and joining us now cbs this morning's
lead
national correspondent david
i really bignow to compliment you
because sometimes when you see
these pieces you feel like it's all
wrapped up in a bow
and it just makes you feel really good
this is not only
a feel-good story but it's very
incentivizing i want to do more
with these women and i hope that other
people feel that too watching it
i think your journalistic style is just
perfection because
it's not like great that's all happening
and taken care of i can move on with my
life it makes me go i want to get
involved well first of all thank you for
allowing me to spread some joy on your
behalf and i have to tell you drew those
women
between the three of them have had six
different cancers almost right six
so the gratitude they feel for just
being alive
was palpable and they were tickled pink
that you thought enough about what
they're doing
to recognize them on your show they were
over the moon it's not enough i want to
do more
you know i've seen many different
interviews with different people but
there's something about when david does
the interview
people open up to him in a way that they
don't to others he really does have a
special gift so i'm not surprised
you recognize that i absolutely did and
out of curiosity
um for all of us budding you know lovers
of
journalism and the art of conversation
how do you get all of this goodness out
of people
i'll tell you what it is for me short
soulful questions
this lady there's nobody like her right
i adore her but what i try and do is i
go in
and just be myself yeah and what i do
what i do drew is a lot of people are
expecting big questions they prep all
night they're like he's going to ask me
the following
and i go in and i go but why did you
the moment you walked in or why didn't
you say that and
it's the simple short soulful that lead
people to sort of go
well you want to know my heart and when
you can give me a piece of your heart
that's where the audience is going to
connect all right david thank you
david and gail catch gail on cbs this
morning
and check out the new oprah daily i love
that it has the word daily
yeah yeah we do too and watch oprah and
gail live tonight on
zoom and go to our website for a special
oprah insider offer that by the way when
i found out what it was my jaw dropped
check it out
[Music]